it's time for the long gene kana scope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Fridays
a presentation of the laun gene which
noir watch company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching Chronos code from the CBS
television news staff Larry Lazar and
Winston predict our distinguished guests
for this evening is dr. Howard Rusk
director of rehabilitation at the New
York University Bellevue Medical Center
and dr. Rossi are best known for your
work at rehabilitating American Air
Force veterans and disabled civilians
how did you happen to become connected
with the American Corie and
rehabilitation mission well I was asked
to go on this mission because I guess my
name was sort of linked with
rehabilitation and Korea was really a
patient in need of such a program I've
had the privilege of going on missions
into Poland and Israel and Finland and
other places and dr. Milton Eisenhower
asked last March that I go over with a
with a mission to try to see what the
needs were and what we could do about it
and I said a very foolish thing when I
accepted I said that I would be glad to
go to come back and make a professional
report but I would not get emotionally
involved you know when you've been to
Korea you know because you've been there
that you never get it out of your heart
or your mind or your backs of your eyes
or your nostrils and I guess I've spent
more than half my time since the first
trip
thinking and working on the problems of
Korea and have been back once since it's
true
dr. Rusk may I ask you is there any
great difference between the
rehabilitation of a disabled veteran or
civilian and rehabilitating a war-torn
country well of course in our Air Force
program and with our veterans program
and now with our civilian program we had
a great medical profession behind it we
had hospitals and we had all the tools
to work with and in the country that's
been devastated like Korea 4,500 years
of culture never fighting an aggressive
war in that time than 50 years under the
heel of the Japs and five years of
freedom and then a country that's been
fought over five times it's very
difficult because there aren't many
tools greatest tool you had there was
the courage of the people could you
describe the health situation there dr.
Ross what are the main health problems
well rather than give you a lot of
statistics I think that if you thought
of any town of 25,000 people Las Vegas
Nevada Portsmouth New Hampshire
Jefferson City Missouri any town of that
size you destroy a fourth of the houses
you on roof a fourth everybody's hungry
on an 1800 calorie diet of 3hops of rice
in the little bowl of kimchi a day
everybody's cold because there's only
enough fuel to warm the food everybody
has intestinal parasites and in the town
of 25,000 there would be 1,500 with
tuberculosis 400 acutely ill there would
be probably 40 or 50 with leprosy the
pneumonia and sinus and cold would be
ten times that in our country with that
situation with no water supply no sewage
and one poorly trained doctor to meet
the needs of that community
that gives you a little idea about the
health situation in Korea
dr. Rusk I don't want to appear to be
hard-hearted about it but tell me do you
think that all this money that we're
giving Korea is going to go down the
drain or the people they are really
willing to work and rebuild the country
themselves well I can only say this that
in the more than a hundred institutions
orphanages hospitals leprous area all
types that we visited in that period of
time I never heard a child cry I never
heard a man groan in pain and I never
heard a Korean asked for anything except
will you help us offer knees so we can
help ourselves and continue to fight
against communism I think that all they
want and all they're begging for is an
opportunity to work to rebuild their
country in the live in peace well dr.
Rusk the United Nations I believe began
the job of rehabilitation in Korea and
we continued it with our recent
appropriation of 200 million dollars why
is it that we're doing that by ourselves
unilaterally rather than going ahead
with the UN well we started with the
United Nations program and there were
two and one was called K CAC which was
prevent starvation and unrest and that
was a program that provided the food and
the blankets and controlled typhoid
typhus malaria and smallpox and then the
long-range UN program was to go in six
months after hostilities but the war
went on so long that it had to begin
earlier but I think that we made this
unilateral deal for two or three reasons
in the first place the Koreans have come
to love and respect the Americans there
are lots more of us there than any other
people their feeling about the GIS and
what they've done the fact that our army
is there to dispense and to give not
only the money but on a voluntary basis
the steam shovels and the bulldozers and
all of the things that they want to help
the Koreans help themselves with
and last but I think probably most
important is a tremendous respect that
the Koreans have for the American people
primarily because we stuck out on a
principle we wouldn't send back the
prisoners of war who didn't want to go
back and I think that's a reason and I
think it was good what about the GIS
feelings about the South Koreans well
when when I tell you that they've given
between thirty and twenty thirty forty
million dollars out of their own a
hundred and fifty dollars a month when
there isn't a Korean outfit over there
that doesn't have an orphanage or a
group of orphans or a hospital or
something that they've done up in Wigan
boo this last trip right up below the
38th parallel a beautiful stone church
that the Catholic boys gave seventy five
hundred dollars out of their own pockets
for the material and they were their
trucks and and all the mechanized
equipment came in and the and the
Koreans built this beautiful church the
Protestant boys build another one down
in the valley and honoring all the
Protestant dead in Korea and these same
boys in one outfit bill seventeen
schools that had been raised and that's
true for one but over and over again
it's I don't think it's ever happened
before in history
dr. Rusk I know that you've seen a
number of Korean veterans clumping
around those streets and Seoul with
wooden legs and I know also that you're
the father of a very noble thought that
there is no such thing as a hopelessly
disabled person but tell me do you think
that the rehabilitation of severely
disabled people really pays dividends I
know it does in our own experience here
and if a man's legs are off the problem
is no different whether he's a Korean or
a Russian or a community community nice
or an American his basic problem is to
say and we know from our experience that
90% of all disabled people can be taught
to do some gainful work and can retain
their dignity
and their desire to live in their place
in society and it's no different in
Korea when doctor Rusk
we read stories in the local papers
justice very day as a matter of fact
from Korea which indicate that president
Syngman Rhee has some grandiose plans
for rebuilding his country with the
money that the United States will
furnish him now will these interfere
with your plans for the rehabilitation
of Korea no I I think some of the plans
may be a little grandiose on the face of
them but actually well we've heard so
much about mystery I think a lot of
people don't remember that for eight
years he was a captive of the Japanese
in his own country and if he would show
you his back there's still the scars
from the green bamboo beatings and if
you talk to the old man now and he gets
excited or tired he'll blow on his
thumbs because he was in the string up
for hours and when you come down
scruciating ly tender I think he's
neither a paragon nor a sinner I think
he's a great Patriot I think he's in
between I think he that his country
means more to him than anything in the
world he's a great student you know he's
a very religious man when he escaped he
came to this country and got his a B
degree at George Washington his master's
at Harvard and his PhD at Princeton in
philosophy and I think that the reason
that he's talking about wide roads and
these other things is the great desire
for the Koreans to feel that they belong
to take their place among the nations of
the world I remember mrs. Reese said
that two things that we'd like to have
in Korea we'd like to have a good hotel
so the boys wouldn't have to go back to
Japan for their holiday and we'd like to
have a hydroponics garden where we could
raise vegetables that American soldiers
would eat and I think that's really the
thing back of this whole business when I
asked you briefly is a final question
dr. Russ do you think the piece is
really going to stick in Korea or at
least the truth well I'm I'm a hopeless
optimist
because of the courage of the people and
because from the reports had come down
that 90% of the North Koreans they say
would come across tomorrow I think when
the people want the peace and when the
world wants the peace and when it's
right and honorable then I can't help
but be an optimist well thank you very
much dr. Rusk it's been a great pleasure
to have you here tonight nice to be back
again the opinions you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight have been
entirely their own the editorial board
for this edition of the launching chroma
scope Larry Lazar and Winston Burdette
our distinguished guest was dr. Howard
Rusk director of rehabilitation at the
New York University Bellevue Medical
Center